la Corte Suprema dictaminó este viernes
que la administración de biden había
excedido Su autoridad con su plan de
eliminar más de 400 mil millones de
dólares en deuda estudiantil frustrando
así las esperanzas de decenas de
millones de prestatarios estudiantiles e
imponiendo nuevas restricciones al poder
ejecutivo según datos del gobierno más
de 45 millones de personas en todo el
país deben uno coma seis billones en
préstamos federales estudiantiles y la
propuesta de cancelación de la deuda
anunciada por biden hace un año habría
sido uno de los decretos más costosos en
la historia del país sin embargo el
presidente dijo desde la casa blanca que
su administración Tratará una nueva
alternativa se trata de Cancelar
préstamos estudiantiles bajo una nueva
ley esta ley se trata de la ley de
educación superior de 1965 que contiene
una disposición que otorga al secretario
de educación Miguel Cardona la autoridad
de comprometer renunciar o liberar
cualquier derecho título reclamo es
decir la capacidad de perdonar deuda
estudiantil para millones de estudiantes
recordemos que esta decisión se da un
día después de que la Corte Suprema haya
limitado la acción afirmativa que le
daba la posibilidad a jóvenes de
minorías negras y latinas entrar a
universidades de calidad en Estados
Unidos